and just remember that we're all human
beings we all have emotions we're all
going through things
- what I announce to the world there's a
lot more I'm going through
Jeffrey star is speaking out about his
cancelled master class tour I know a lot
of you like Jeffrey why are you know in
Europe right now
fans have been speculating that the
makeup mogul split with Nathan chuan was
his reason for breaking off the plan
tour with mamama Mitchell there's no
easy way to say this but we didn't break
up Jeffrey took to Instagram on Tuesday
to set the record straight obviously you
guys know I've been going through a lot
not just the breakup but it's really
hard to leave the dogs I have a lot less
help right now so I just wanna clear the
air
the jeffree star cosmetics owner is well
known for the love he has for his dogs
drama diva delicious and davinci I'm
pointing everyone Jeffrey told his 15.6
million Instagram followers that
spending ten days in Europe was just too
much right now the thought of leaving my
dogs for that long when their father is
not here couldn't even bear them not
wanting to worry his fans Jeffrey made
it clear that his breakup with Nate had
taken a toll but he's hanging in there
I'm doing okay am i doing great
absolutely not
but that's okay so I'm not sure who
needs to hear this but it's okay do not
be okay in the YouTube video announcing
the Paris split
Jeffrey expressed how much he and Nate
still care for each other I will always
have love for him are we in love with
each other
no but we love each other and he will
always be in my life
[Music]